what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have a lot to talk about in
regards to the Avengers and not just the
next Avengers film but the next two
Avengers films that we're going to be
getting before Avengers Secret Wars one
of those of course is Avengers 5 which
was formerly of course Avengers King
Dynasty now simply titled Avengers 5
until a new title gets released however
we might have a tiny bit of news on that
front it's more of a speculated rumor at
this point in time but an Insider could
have hinted at the possible new title
for Avengers 5 we also have rumored
details about what the plot of the film
was or possibly is going to be depending
if Marvel Studios changes it but from
what we've heard Marvel Studios doesn't
plan to change too much and that Kang is
still going to be the main big bad of
the Multiverse Saga which I have to say
that I agree with that decision because
Kang has already been set up in too many
ways at this point in time and
unfortunately whether you believe
Jonathan major was innocent or guilty
despite him being found guilty and
whether you believe he should come back
or not it looks like Marvel Studios is
not going to bring him back which means
they should just recast the character
and move on they shouldn't get rid of
the character altogether but according
to several insiders King is still the
villain of the Multiverse Saga we are
not diving into a new main big bad which
again I think is the right move because
too much has been set up focusing on
King but let's talk about this we'll
call it a plot leak for Avengers King
Dynasty and some other Avengers news as
well and if you want to stay up to date
on the MCU and all of the Avengers teams
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
we're also doing a big giveaway more on
that at the end so a few rumors flying
around this morning on Twitter on
Instagram everywhere and one is about
Jeff lovess being fired from Avengers
the King Dynasty and I'm mentioning this
because Marvel St Studios has recently
been nominated for an award that they
have never been nominated for before and
it's not a great award and it's
connected to the King Dynasty now Jeff
lenus was supposed to write Avengers the
King Dynasty but he also already wrote
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania which
has gotten a lot of flak a lot of
criticism and in my opinion some
unnecessary hate not saying it was great
but gez but according to some rumors
going around right now Jeff lovess was
supposedly fired from Avengers the King
Dynasty after the negative reactions
from Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
and now it's been revealed that Ant-Man
and the WASP has been nominated for
three different Razzi Awards and if
you're not aware of what the Razzi
awards are they are basically the worst
of awards and Marvel Studios themselves
have never been even put up for this
morbius has and other things like 20th
century foxes Fantastic 4 have but never
anything from Marvel Studios they have
been put up for the worst supporting
actor including Michael Douglas and
newcomer Bill Murray worst director for
pton Reed and unfortunately worst
prequel remake ripoff or sequel category
again not really sure it deserves all of
that but that goes hand inand with
Marvel Studios firing Jeff lovess from
the King Dynasty because of all the
negative reactions that Quantum Mania
received but with this news also comes
rumors of what the plot for his Avengers
film was going to be for the Kang
Dynasty according to the rumors Kang
dynasty was reportedly going to gather
all the leads of the Multiverse Saga
except for Thor to fight against Kang
variants on Earth the film would have
felt grounded and not involved too many
multiversal elements and in my opinion I
think a lot of people would have
probably liked that now this could very
well still happen the only question is
will Marvel Studios still include King
the Conqueror in this film because a
couple of different insiders recently
have have been hinting that the new
Avengers film Avengers 5 could simply be
titled the new Avengers which makes
sense and is very fitting because right
now we don't really have an Avengers
team so this would be the new Avengers
team the old Avengers team is done
Captain America's on the moon Iron Man
and Black Widow are no longer here Thor
is apparently not going to be in the
next Avengers film and the Hulk might be
a part of the new team but we do have
She-Hulk and Professor Hulk is not
really the same Hulk that we knew from
the beginning plus we'll have a new
leader with Sam Wilson's Captain America
and the team will mostly be newcomers so
the new Avengers is a pretty fitting
title now as far as them fighting Kang
variants on Earth well Quantum Mania did
set that up especially at the end where
Antman is asking himself did he actually
save everybody or did he Doom everybody
Ant-Man has been reported to be a part
of the new Avengers team along with the
wasp and this makes sense because of
everything they just dealt with with
Kang and again I think with everything
Marvel Studios has done they're in a
little bit too deep to kind of push away
from King and since the next Avengers
film isn't going to be out for a few
years they have time to figure
everything out with recasting King and
how they're going to move forward to
where I think that even if they do
decide to rename the next Avengers film
The New Avengers Kang is still going to
be a part of it because the Multiverse
is still going to be falling apart and
incursions are going to be happening
because of Kang and all of his variants
and we know that in the next Avengers
film The ERS are probably going to lose
so having them go up against Kang
variance is probably what's going to
make them lose so even though Jeff less
might not be riding the next Avengers
film I do think it's going to be
somewhat like this I still think it's
going to be a very grounded film I do
think it's going to have most of the
leads not all of them I know Thor is not
going to be there we still don't know
about the Scarlet Witch and I don't
think Doctor Strange is going to be
there as well because according to Alex
P from the cosmic circus The Avengers
won't have doctor strange and that is
why they lose so whoever the Avengers
are going up against with the new
Avengers team they lose and that sets up
Secret Wars and that sets up the
multiversal Avengers team because the
Avengers know they're going to need
people heroes from everywhere but like I
mentioned there is another Avengers team
coming and that is the Young Avengers
according to the account great phase the
Young Avengers project is actively in
development at Marvel Studios with a
potential release date as early as 2026
now this comes as a little to no
surprise because the Marvels set this up
very blatantly and obviously we had Miss
Marvel go to Kate Bishop where we
basically saw the start of the Young
Avengers they even mentioned Scott
Lang's daughter Cassie Lang so right off
the bat we have three Young Avengers
Miss Marvel Kate Bishop's Hawkeye and
Cassie Lang now it's interesting
according to insiders the Young Avengers
project was formally Vision Quest the
Disney plus series that Marvel Studios
was developing now this project was
rumored early on to set up the Young
Avengers so it would make makes sense
that Marvel Studios would simply just
change it into a Young Avengers film
they probably realized that that might
be a little bit more appealing than a
Vision Quest show especially since Bob
Iger and Kevin fige have pretty much
decided they're not going to make
something unless they think it's going
to be very good and it's been pretty
evident recently that Marvel Studios and
Disney really are changing things over
at Disney and Marvel Studios this would
also line up with the firing of Jeff
lovess off of Avengers King Dynasty in
their eyes quantam Mania wasn't
receiving very well it didn't perform
very well so they don't want the same
thing to happen with their next project
especially when it's a huge project like
The Avengers now it's unfortunate that
they fired Jeff lovess because I think
that the connectivity is a good thing
with the MCU and since he wrote Quantum
Mania with king in it the new Avengers
film could have turned out pretty well
however Marvel Studios wants to make
sure that it's great which of course I
always support will always support them
trying to make the best possible movie
and show if it's a show they possibly
can especially with with so many
upcoming exciting projects but let me
know what you think about this news in
the comments down below is this what you
would like the plot for Kang Dynasty
Avengers 5 new Avengers whatever you
want to call it to be would you like
this movie let us know down below please
don't forget to like this video And
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
the MCU and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of every month you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof